hi everyone I'm Peter Brown and this is
a game spot breaking news update their
current rumors of turmoil between Kojima
Productions the studio behind miliar
solid and Konami the parent publisher an
inside source has confirmed a GameSpot
that currently is expected that Kojima
will be leaving after the completion of
Metal Gear Solid 5 because him and other
staff at Kojima Productions are now only
under contract a fallout between Kojima
Productions and as owning publisher
Konami has led the senior staff at the
studio being restricted access to
corporate Internet emails and phone and
inside sources confirmed along with
restricted communications key developers
at the studio including Hideo Kojima
will now have limited opportunities to
lend their appearance to promotions of
the studio's upcoming game Metal Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain power struggle
between Kojima Productions and Konami
have led the publisher to make drastic
changes including the employee status of
the Metal Gear team some senior staff at
the studio including Kojima now
essentially work as contractors not
permanent employees of Konami the
extraordinary measures were revealed by
a source within the studio's speaking of
GameSpot on the condition of anonymity
the person explained that once the
phantom pain project is finished and all
likelihood the management at the studio
will disband from Konami after we
finished melior Solid 5 mr. Kojima and
upper management will leave Konami they
said their contract ends in December the
source claimed the person added at a
team meeting mr. Kojima explained that
the team have to be one and make a good
game for fans in other developments
Konami has begun removing the Kojima
Productions logo from all official Metal
Gear art and it has removed Kojima from
its executive team
meanwhile Kojima Productions branding
has also been removed from Twitter the
official melior Solid website and even
the LA office listing representatives
for Konami would not discuss specifics
of the matter when contacted by GameSpot
corporation has offered a statement it
reads Konami Digital Entertainment
including mr. Kojima will continue to
develop and support milligram products
please look forward to future
announcements this is obviously very big
news for Metal Gear Solid fans the
future of the series is up to Konami not
Hideo Kojima even though it's his
creation he made it while as an employee
at Konami they own the series and the
studio
Kojima Productions but Kojima could
leave and make a studio on his own and
potentially work with Konami down the
road if an amicable agreement is reached
however there's no indication that that
is the case it seems as though
Kojima and other members of the staff
feel burned by Konami and this will be
their last effort with the team for more
news on that front stay tuned and
GameSpot calm